[musique]
Ravier Brasonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle qui
vous présenter.
Pelle Xavier Place, je travaille pour
Bloomberg Opinion. Ça fait 25 ans que je
travaille sur l'énergie et les matières
premières avec un focus sur le pétrole.
J'ai vu des prix à 150 dollars jusqu'à
et puis au niveau de 40 dollars et tout
entre les deux si vous voulez. Je
m'intéresse au monde du commerce des
matières premières. Ce sont des hommes
principalement des hommes qui achètent
qui vendent des matières premières euh
au niveau physique du brut qui ensuite
est produit et amené jusqu'au
consommateur après raffinage. J'ai écrit
un livre qui a été publié en français il
y a quelques mois qui s'appelle le monde
à vendre sur ces courtiers, sur ces
traders, sur leur histoire, sur ce
qu'ils font et sur la maison dont ils
travaillent. On est très content de vous
recevoir.
voudrait avoir en une phrase
votre perception
march
et les répercussions
population.
Les matières premières
sont absolument
essentiel, nécessaire à ce que nous
faisons. Notre vie est impensable
sans l'ensemble des matières premières
que nous consommons.
Comment le dire en une phrase ?
Je vais dire ça. La première chose que
nous faisons le matin en nous levant,
c'est d'allumer la lumière.
C'est le début de notre notre
consommation de matière première et tout
ce qui suit. Ensuite, lorsque vous
éteignez la lumière, cette électricité
est déjà une matière première qui a été
vendue, qui a été achetée. Mais derrière
cette électricité, il y a d'autres
matières premières car cette électricité
doit être produite et ainsi de suite.
Toute est une matière première
durant vos enquêtes qui vont durant vos
interview
à être menacé.
Non, je n'ai pas été menacé
physiquement.
Je me suis rendu dans beaucoup de pays
dans le monde. J'ai été expulsé à
plusieurs reprises. Voilà, on m'a mis,
on m'a on m'a expulsé, on m'a emmené à
l'aéroport. Alors, j'ai été expulsé
d'Iran. J'ai été expulsé de Guinée
équatoriale. En fait, ils m'ont mis en
prison pour quelques heures. Mais bon,
c'est ça allait.
Ça allait. Je suis resté quelques heures
et ensuite ils m'ont ramené à l'aéroport
après.
Et j'ai eu un peu peur que je m'en suis
rendu compte.
On m'a mis dans un avion d'Air France
et ensuite nous sommes rentrés à Paris.
L'équipage d'Air France s'est bien
occupé de moi et lorsque j'ai atterri à
Charles de Gaulle,
j'ai pas mal bu ce ce soir-là.
Les traders en mère première, ils ne
vous menacent pas physiquement, ils ont
des avocats qui s'occupent de vous.
Alors, tout le monde dans cette
industrie bien sûr ne voulait pas que ce
que ce livre soit publié, mais je crois
que c'est normal quand on fait du
journalisme sur le monde des affaires et
le public suit.
Est-ce que vous avez rencontré des chefs
d'état
?
Il y a plusieurs pays dont les matières
premières sont très importantes.
On parle de pétrole. Bien sûr,
le pétrole pour les pays pour les pays
du Moyen-Orient, c'est la principale
c'est la principale source de revenus et
ils veulent bien sûr générer le maximum
de revenus. Je dirais pas qu'il y a eu
des menaces, mais de l'influence sur ce
que nous écrivons
pour que le prix du pétrole soit plus
haut, le prix du cuivre soit plus haut.
Bien sûr, c'est ce qu'ils font chaque
jour.
Et inversement en miroir, les pays qui
consomment ces matières premières
insistent pour que le prix diminue.
Chacun tente d'influencer le marché. Les
journalistes, les analystes, les
consultants,
les traders pour que le prix soit ce
qu'ils veulent.
Alors, on les écoute. Parfois, on peut
être d'accord avec certaines choses
qu'ils disent. Parfois, il faut ignorer
ce qu'ils disent.
Mais cela va de paire,
je ne dirais pas avec une menace,
mais je dirais que ça fait partie de mon
quotidien que d'avoir affaire à des
gens, à des pays qui sont au pouvoir,
des gens qui sont au pouvoir qui me
disent ce qu'ils veulent voir être écrit
dans le journal.
Mais ça, vous savez, c'est
c'est le quotidien que je vis.
Est-ce que des services de renseignement
de puissance étrangère
alors les gens
qui disent qu'ils travaillent pour les
ministères des affaires étrangères de
certains pays
viennent vous voir et demandent des
informations.
Ce sont des gens à qui vous parlez très
régulièrement. Est-ce qu'il travaille
aussi avec les services de renseignement
? Je pense que c'est le cas pour
certains d'entre eux. D'autres sont des
diplomates tout à fait normaux et vous
savez la frontière entre un diplomate et
un espéron parfois est assez tenue. Où
est-ce que ça commence ? Où est-ce que
ça finit ? C'est assez difficile à dire.
Je crois,
j'écris beaucoup sur le monde du pétrole
et il y a beaucoup de pays qui ont un
intérêt fort dans ce domaine et je parle
à tout le monde mais je ne collabore pas
avec eux mais je suis toujours heureux
d'être de parler avec les gens, de
partager un bon repas, d'accéder à des
informations, d'en partager. Ça aussi ça
fait partie du métier du journalistme.
Vous parlez à tout le monde, vous
écoutez tout le monde et ensuite vous
apportez vos contributions.
Mais je sais qu'ils viennent à moi avec
un objectif que ce soit un un
consommateur, un producteur, un
diplomate. Tout le monde a un objectif,
un angle, une perspective pour
m'influencer. Mon métier est d'écouter
chacun et de tirer mes propres
conclusions.
Je voudrais avoir vos conclusions
concernant le pic
pétrole
de faire sortir de l'énergie
urum
de croissant
Bien sûr, bien sûr qu'ils le savent.
Regardez ce qui conditionne l'auto
d'inflation. Et ben l'un des facteurs
principaux, c'est euh les matières
premières. Après, bien sûr, il y a la
masse monétaire en circulation.
L'inflation, c'est un sujet monétaire,
mais les matières premières sont très
importantes,
surtout les matières premières qui
touchent le quotidien.
Les gouvernements s'intéressent beaucoup
à l'énergie, électricité, gaz naturel,
pétrole, mais également les prix de
l'alimentation des matières premières
donc qui touchent le quotidien.
Donc vraiment tout toutes les matières
premières qui ont un impact sur les vie
quotidiennes, le diesel, le gasoil, la
nourriture bien sûr exactement dans les
supermarchés très important.
Et parfois
la nourriture n'est même pas forcément
une matière première critique de notre
quotidien quand on se demande le prix
des légumes, le prix des viandes, mais
également le prix du café. Je vais au je
vais au supermarché, je vois que le café
est à un prix record, je me dis "Mon
dieu, qu'est-ce que c'est cher !"
Puisque les prix que j'ai encore en tête
ne sont pas ceux euh que je paye
aujourd'hui, c'est x 2. Donc les
gouvernements
suivent de très près le prix des des
matières premières. Il y a une chose qui
ne cesse de me surprendre,
c'est que à part c'est qu'à part un
nombre limité de gouvernement,
les États ne comprennent pas vraiment
comment les marchés des matières
premières fonctionnent. Vous parlez aux
banques centrales, aux ministres des
finances, ils ne savent pas vraiment
comment fonctionnent ces marchés des
matières premières et ils en savent
encore moins sur la façon dont ces
matières premières sont échangées.
Alors bien sûr, c'est agréable pour mon
ego que de recevoir l'appel d'un
gouverneur de banque centrale pour que
je le renseigne sur une matière
première. Bon, gouverneur de telle ou
telle banque centrale qui me demande euh
mon avis sur le prix du gaz ou euh du
pétrole, mais je suis un journaliste,
j'ai écrit un livre sur les matières
premières, mais j'imagine qu'il y a des
fonctionnaires, des gens qui sont mieux
à même de répondre à ces questions. Et
au fur et à mesure des années, j'ai fini
par comprendre qu'il n'y avait pas
vraiment une compréhension fine pour un
phénomène qui est aussi crucial pour
l'économie mondiale et pour la politique
puisquon fait la guerre pour ces
matières premières. Les gouvernements,
les États occidentaux ne comprennent pas
vraiment la façon dont ces marchés
fonctionnent et surtout la façon dont
ils sont articulés les uns avec les
autres. Et ça me surprend.
On va poser la question suivante d'une
façon très différé
si ils ont si peu d'informations qu'ils
sont obligés d'appeler un journaliste
Bloomberg,
comment vous imaginez leur capacité ou
comment vous évaluez leur capacité à
faire des prospects
long terme.
Je crains mon cher qu'il n'it pas cette
capacité.
Beaucoup ignorent vraiment ce qui se
passe.
Je vais le dire différemment. Parfois
les gens me demandent "Pensez-vous qu'il
qu'il faille davantage réguler ce marché
?" Et je réponds de manière un peu
standard.
Oui, probablement. Mais d'abord, il faut
qu'on comprenne mieux les choses. On ne
peut pas réguler quelque chose qu'on ne
comprend pas. La première chose, c'est
de mieux comprendre ce qui se passe, que
ce soit sur l'offre, sur la demande.
Alors, on me demande "Faut-il réguler
davantage les traders ? Faut-il que ce
soit mieux réglementé ? J'aimerais que
les États les connaissent mieux,
connaissent
ce qu'ils gagnent et comment il le
gagne.
Donc les États prennent des décisions
sur l'économie,
leurs actions, leurs décisions ont un
impact sur les marchés
bien sûr,
mais il n'est pas possible, il est
difficile
de réguler s'ils sont quasiment
aveugles, s'ils n'ont pas les
informations pertinentes.
Et le pétrole est peut-être la matière
première la plus importante. pétrole
et la matière première sur laquelle nous
avons le plus d'informations. Mais vous
allez ensuite sur d'autres marchés, les
métaux, les marchés agricoles et on ne
sait même pas ce qu'elle offre sur ces
marchés. On ne connaît pas précisément
la demande, manque des données de base
et on ne sait pas non plus quels sont
les niveaux des stocks.
Quand vous pensez aux matières premières
agricoles, les plus importantes,
probablement la plus importante, le riz
qui nourrit la euh la moitié de la
population mondiale et on ignore les
stocks mondiaux de riz. Actuellement, on
ignore
combien de riz, quelle quantité de riz
est stocké en Chine, ce qui est pourtant
absolument critique pour comprendre ce
marché.
Je ne crois pas que les États puissent
se projeter
car il semble manquer des information de
base.
Peut-être qu'on peut vouloir en savoir
plus sur les marchés. Enfin, je crois
que c'est le cas depuis longtemps
puisqu'il y a une proposition G7 portant
sur un registre des transactions
physiques de pétrole.
Si une raffinerie achète un cargo de
pétrole brut, alors il fait cette
raffinerie fait enregistrer euh sa
livraison et les prix.
Donc ça, on pourrait dire que c'est euh
que c'est du pur bon sens et que c'est
essentiel pour mettre en place les
sections contre la Russie ou l'Iran et
pour mieux comprendre de manière
générale comment le marché fonctionne et
où il est. Ça fait longtemps qu'on y
réfléchit. La première proposition au G7
sur ce registre a eu lieu en 1979.
Voilà. Mais ça prend du temps donc et je
ne crois pas que cela sera mis
véritablement en place.
Mais la première proposition de
transparence dans ces marchés a été
faite en 79.
Est-ce que ça vous terrifie en tant que
citoyen
qui vit dans une économie occidentale ?
Le fait que on est des capitaines sans
gens qui regardent loin. Vous connaissez
les intrication et les
comment comment je pourrais vous
expliquer les intrications et les
conséquences
d'un d'une pénurie ou d'un un
approvisionnement pointiller. Vous êtes
les deux mains dans le comboui en terme
d'information. Est-ce que ça vous
terrifie d'entendre des hommes
politiques ou des femmes politiques
faire des plans sur la comète, faire des
grandes déclarations grandiloquantes ?
Est-ce que quand vous les écoutez, vous
vous dites "Ces gens sont fous, ces gens
ment ou est-ce que ces gens ne savent
pas où ils vont ?
about the commodity markets particularly
about the energy market
and I'm thinking
I really hope that they have better
information about everything else
because it sounds like they are just
making it up at least on oil and andery
and then I'm thinking so when they are
deciding whether to go to war or they
are deciding to social policy or tax or
whatever it is I'm thinking I mean
surely they know better uh that they
know in commodies
peu
bien sûr, je généralise, certains sont
mieux informés que d'autres. Le
gouvernement américain bien sûr est bien
mieux informé sur les marchés des
matières premières que les autres.
Nous dépendons au niveau mondial
beaucoup des statistiques américaines.
Si vous aussi vous voulez savoir combien
les Européens ont récolté de pl cette
année-là
dans le secteur privé,
vous pouvez soit attendre 6 mois que la
Commission européenne produise les
chiffres ou alors vous pouvez consulter
les chiffres produits mensuellement par
les Américains. Cela vous dit beaucoup
sur la façon euh
sur la façon dont les Européens
collectent les données. Quand on
quand on demande les données à
Bruxelles, souvent ils vous fournissent
les données du ministère de
l'agriculture américaine. Ça dit long.
Mais ce qui me terrifie vraiment,
c'est la chose suivante.
Dans les matières premières,
je ne sais pas s'il
s'ils savent
s'ils prennent les décisions de la même
manière par exemple pour la politique
étrangère.
Il y a eu cette révolte.
Il y a eu cette révolte en Libye où on a
renversé Mohamar Kaddafi
et avait-il des meilleures informations
qu'on est soutien à l'Ukraine ? Quel est
le niveau d'information ?
Et je sais que sur le sujet que je
connais bien, les matières premières sur
ce sujet-là, je sais qu'ils en
connaissent très peu. Je sais que les
Américains sont mieux informés, les
Chinois sont très bien informés de leur
propre marché, mais au-delà,
je crains qu'il n'y ait pas beaucoup de
connaissances d'information.
bien sûr des producteurs importants
comme le le cuivre, l'état sûr. Nous
allons mettre l'économie russe à genoux.
Ensuite, on a entendu
au l'Union européenne la femme en charge
de l'énergie dire "C'est une guerre
énergétique mais nous avons un plan."
Et on a un plan. Ah bon ?
J'étais pas au courant.
J'ai entendu que l'économie russe était
au point de s'effondrer
depuis le 2e jour de l'invasion de
l'Ukraine
et même depuis l'invasion de l'Ukraine
il y a plus de 10 ans en Crimé et ça n'a
pas eu lieu.
Peut-être que ça aura lieu. Il y a des
impacts cumulés des sanctions
importants. Les sanctions
ne sont pas bien appliquées. Il y a des
failles et cetera. euh mais feront leur
chemin. Euh euh il y a le 19e 19e train
de sanction euh par le l'Union
européenne, les Américain aussi. Donc il
y aura des impacts. Le prix du pétrole
n'est pas est loin de 100 de dollars 100
dollars
et on a vu ce point être touché avant le
la guerre. c'est à 60 dollars. Donc
c'est la moitié, ça a un impact sur
l'économie.
Mais nous sous-estimons la résilience de
l'économie russe bien souvent
et le peu de préparation européen
vis-à-vis de la guerre. Certains
fonctionnaires américaines
disaient euh à l'Europe qu'il fallait
faire attention avant la guerre.
Euh monsieur Hobstein, notamment un des
conseillers du président Biden disait
"Je me souviens plus quel pays, mais il
disait dans un discours,
il l'avertissait
en disant "Si l'Europe continue
dépendante de la Russie, ça va provoquer
des problèmes". Et
je me souviens
que Bruxelles pensait qu'il se trompa,
c'était un alarmiste
et ils l'ont rejeté et il avait raison
sur toute la ligne. Finalement, ça a
créé des problèmes.
Donc l'Europe n'a pas de plan, pas un
bon plan en tout cas. Et nous avons
sous-estimé
l'économie russe globalement.
Est-ce que la Russie pourrait connaître
l'effondrement ? Oui, c'est possible.
Le cours du pétrole à 60 dollars, ça ça
aura un impact. Nous verrons bien,
mais ceux qui prédisaient la
l'effondrement russe,
on les entend depuis 4 ans, si ce n'est
plus et la Russie est toujours dans le
combat. Donc je ne pense pas que le
monde va se terminer après
l'effondrement russe. Ce sera pour
d'autres raisons.
Est-ce que vous pensez que l'économie
européenne
va péricliter
avant l'économie russe ? L'économie
européenne va se casser la figure.
Non, l'économie européenne est beaucoup
plus diversifiée que celle de Russie.
Beaucoup plus de de d'élans. Mais
l'Europe est une démocratie. La Russie
ne l'est pas vraiment.
Les gouvernements européens
et les responsables politiques en Europe
ressentiront la douleur de tout
ralentissement économique bien plus tôt
que monsieur Vladimir Poutine.
Donc le seuil de douleur économique qui
peut provoquer des changements
politiques en Europe par rapport à la
Russie est bien différent. un petit
ralentissement un peu d'inflation en
Europe aura un impact
et alors que pas du tout en Russie ou
très peu.
Nous nous avons l'habitude de vivre de
bonnes vies, c'est une bonne chose. Euh
et grâce à mon emploi, j'ai
j'ai beaucoup voyagé dans une centaine
de pays et je me sens très chanceux
chanceux d'être né en Espagne et pas
ailleurs.
Et l'Espagne n'est pas le pays le plus
riche d'Europe. Euh j'étais à 50 km
de la frontière
française. Si j'étais né de l'autre
côté, j'aurais eu une meilleure vie
encore. Mais bon, je ne parle pas assez
bien français et je ne pourrais pas
faire cette interview en français en
tout cas. Mais vous voyez, les seuils de
douleur sont importants. Un
ralentissement en Europe pourrait
provoquer des dégâts économiques graves
et cela provoquerait des conséquences.
les gouvernements,
peu importe de droite ou de gauche,
nous avons vu certains pays flanché d'un
côté ou de l'autre
et souvent il y a un rejet des électeurs
des pouvoirs en place et ça ça se fait
de droite ou de gauche.
On va discuter maintenant
guerre économique.
Est-ce que les journalistes
ont des capacités à connecter différents
domaines pour informer correctement la
population en terme ? Je vois je vous
vois commencer à sourire.
Laissez-moi terminer parce que les
interprètes sinon après ça va être
compliqué. On les embrasse les
interprètes d'ailleurs.
You want to rebond ? Go ahead. Oh bah
polite with me friend. OK. I'm going to
rebound.
Donc, est-ce que vous pensez que il
reste encore des journalistes old school
qui se réunissent autour d'un petit thé
et qui échange en disant notre
population, nos auditeurs, nos lecteurs
avec notre devoir de les informer pour
qu'ils puissent prendre leur décision en
leur ramer conscience. Est-ce qu'il
reste encore des groupes de journalistes
suffisamment
armés, informés avec des sources
primaires d'information pour dire
maintenant les gouvernements utilisent
la majeure partie de la presse comme
relais de leur propagande, que ce soit
en Europe, en Russie, aux États-Unis, en
Afrique. Et le monde commence à sentir
leur mensonge, à sentir leur mensonge
dans leurs assiettes, dans leur frigo.
Est-ce qu'il reste encore des
journalistes
dédiés à informer des gens qui sont
considérés par les traders, les
gouvernements et tous les autres comme
une masse informe et stupide ?
surtout pour ce qui concerne les guerres
commerciales, il y a deux difficultés
pour les journalistes. Première et qu'il
que nous n'avons pas assez d'expérience.
C'est la première fois que nous vivons,
en tout cas les journalistes de mon âge,
40 50 ans, nous n'avons pas vécu de
guerre commerciale telle que celle
d'aujourd'hui.
L'expérience est importante.
Je parle à mes collègues dans la salle
de presse, sur les marchés. Je l'ai déjà
dit,
j'ai vu différentes projections sur les
cours du pétrole et il évolue toute
façon et on vérifie nos nos projections.
L'expérience est importante, mais nous
n'avons pas d'expérience
sur sur ça. Les journalistes
font des projections et font des
hypothèses. Nous n'avons pas de boussole
de cartes. nous apprenons en faisant et
c'est important parce que sans avoir
l'expérience
et bien vous faites plus d'erreur. C'est
une difficulté. Ensuite
c'est que c'est un sujet
très important. c'est il faut s'y
connaître dans différents domaines. Le
négoce du soja, pourquoi les comment les
agriculteurs américains vendent leur
sojat au au Chinois ? Il faut connaître,
il faut aussi connaître sur les les
puces, comment les les puces très
simples sont essentielles pour produire
des voitures. Euh il faut connaître les
complexités des chaînes
d'approvisionnement de l'industrie
occidentale
comme nous produisons à la minute. Oui,
on parle de puce, on se dit "Bon, les
grands fabricants d'automobiles ont du
stock de 3 mois." Non, pas du tout. Ils
ont quelques jours peut-être, peut-être
pas du tout. Euh, il dépendent de euh de
de de d'envoi à la minute. Donc
moi, je peux parler euh de ce que je
connais, du soja, euh du pétrole,
la l'offre énergétique, mais je ne m'y
connais pas en puce,
en en voiture, le FTAN, le trafic de
drogue et d'autres sujets. Et puis il
faut ici connaître les moteurs de la
politique chinoise,
la politique américaine aussi.
Donc traiter la question de la guerre
commerciale implique beaucoup d'efforts
chez les journalistes. Et pour ceux qui
nous écoutent,
je dirais ne vous fiez pas aux histoires
simples parce que aucun journaliste
connaît tous ces secteurs.
Compiler plusieurs histoires, plusieurs
reportages et on le voit dans la salle
de réaction rédaction. Certains écrivent
sur les métaux, d'autres spécialistes
écrivent sur les voitures, l'automobile,
d'autres écrivent sur les relations
américaine américaino chinoise. Et cette
connaissance combinée nous permet de
raconter l'histoire. Mais c'est une
histoire complexe et je reconnais que ce
sont des faits difficiles à traiter
et
nous n'avons pas de référence historique
ou des références connues. Les
références connues datent des années 30
et nous n'avons pas vécu cette époque.
C'est seulement à cette époque qu'on a
des faits similaires. Donc le manque de
référence historique récente
a un impact et pour moi couvrir la
guerre commerciale est difficile.
Je parlais avec vous de votre peur, ce
qui vous terrorise concernant le manque
d'information de nos gouvernements.
Quand vous marchez dans la rue avec
toutes les informations que vous avez pu
aller chercher avec les dents ou avec
votre plume ou avec votre micro,
quand vous regardez les gens qui sont
censés avoir des pilotes, des
politiciens mettant un câine dans la
tempête, quand vous voyez leur capacité
à prendre des décisions à court, moyen
et surtout long terme,
est-ce que votre regard se pose sur eux
comme si c'était des fantômes dirigés
par des annes.
Je crois qu'ils font face au même
problème que les journalistes
dans la guerre commerciale.
Vous connaissez vous connaissez
l'expression très célèbre heureux les
simples d'esprit aujourd'hui j'ai
compris
bien sûr ils ont plus d'informations que
moi.
Mais
pour beaucoup d'entre eux,
c'est la première fois que les
États-Unis affrontent la Chine de
manière commerciale à ce niveau-là.
Il y a déjà eu des petites escarmouches
commerciales par le passé, mais rien de
ce niveau. Et ça ne concerne pas que les
États-Unis, ça concerne aussi l'Europe.
D'ailleurs,
il faut dire ce que c'est.
On a une guerre commerciale
internationale, une guerre de tous
contre tous.
Les États-Unis
affrontent différents pôles, différents
pays.
Certains pays sont alliés avec les
États-Unis dans certains domaines et les
affrontent dans d'autres. Et je crois
que le monde politique a beaucoup de
difficultés pour comprendre ce qu'il
doit faire.
Et je ne sais pas,
je n'ai pas l'expertise.
Je ne sais pas ce qu'est l'objectif de
l'Amérique. J'ignore ce que la maison ce
que la Maison Blanche
considérera être une victoire à court
terme et surtout l'objectif à atteindre
dans 10 12 ans.
croit que l'État américain et la Maison
Blanche ont des ont des définitions
différentes de cette victoire et c'est
un problème supplémentaire à prendre en
compte. Pour revenir sur ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure
que ce il y a ce monde politique en
France, au Royaume-Uni où je vis aux
États-Unis, combien de ces hommes et
femmes politiques comprennent vraiment
les détails
des éléments qui sont sur la table des
négociations ? Les chefs d'État
négocient
ce qui a déjà été prémaché par les
fonctionnaire.
Mais qu'en est-il des droits de douane
sur tels et tels intrans chimiques qu'
faut avec lesquels on fait ensuite des
médicaments ? Qu'en est-il ?
Des droits de douanes sur les
importations de soja aux États-Unis sur
les exportations pardon. Qu'en est-il
des minéraux critiques ? Qu'en est-il
du fait que les microprocesseurs
utilise des terres rares qui sont
traités par la Chine ?
Y a-t-il quelqu'un qui comprenne
vraiment le détail de tous ces dossiers
? Cela me surprendrait. J'espère qu'ils
ont de des bons conseils.
Mais lorsque la Maison Blanche annonce
un nouveau droit de douane et puis vous
voyez qu'on balance quelques chiffres et
que ces chiffres ne sont pas vraiment
compréhensible,
peut-être que ils sont inventés au fur
et à mesure un peu spontanément,
mais tout cela est neuf
et je crois que nous avons tous du mal
surtout le personnel politique.
Avant de parler de de des mécanismes
d'influence
des matières premières et de ceux à la
tête de ces mécanismes,
je voudrais revenir sur ma question.
Vous, quand vous posez votre regard sur
la population,
quand vous croisez des gens dans la rue,
quand vous croisez des gens au
supermarché, au restaurant et que vous
vous dites, ils n'ont pas une
honnaissance
du niveau de merde qu'on est à l'heure
actuelle.
Vous avez de la compassion pour eux.
Moi, une chose qui m'a beaucoup frustré,
c'est quand la crise énergétique a
commencé en Europe.
Nous, journalistes, il fallait qu'on
fasse un meilleur travail d'explication.
Tout au début de la crise énergétique.
Moi, j'avais averti, je savais que les
prix allaient exploser
plusieurs centaines de pourcent. Les
gens disaient non non 10 20 30 % j'ai et
moi je disais non 100 % 200 % c'est ça
la fourchette c'était une fourchette
bien différente.
Parfois je suis perplexe.
Je me demande ce que les gens
comprennent dans la rue des marchés des
matières premières. Je le vois chez moi.
J'étais avec un ami. Nous parlions du
pétrole.
Nous parlions d'objectif de diminution
des émissions
et on m'a dit pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut
pas faire avec le pétrole ce qu'on a
déjà fait avec le avec le charbon ?
Qu'est-ce que tu veux dire ? Et je lui
ai répondu et il m'a dit bah on s'est
débarrassé du charbon. On peut on pourra
sûrement se se débarrasser du pétrole,
n'est-ce pas ? Je lui dis mais de quoi
tu me parles ? On sait pas débarrasser
du charbon.
La production de charbon atteint le
niveau record et ça continu à monter en
particulier en Chine. Il était perplexe.
Il n'avait pas vraiment confiance en moi
et ça en dit long d'ailleurs euh sur la
confiance de la population générale en
dans les journalistes.
Je ferme la parenthèse.
Donc il
sur son téléphone, il a regardé la la
demande de charbon au niveau mondial et
puis il a vu que ça tenait des records.
Donc il y a une véritable déconnexion
entre ce que connaît la population
et les réalités du marché.
Et il y a également une déconnexion
importante.
Je je ne sais pas pourquoi
plutôt comme sont différemment
pour en pour en apprendre sur certaines
mat première j'étudie les chaînes
d'approvisonnement sur le café par
exemple vous allez dans un pays
producteur dans une plantation et vous
tentez ensuite de suivre les grains de
café.
Euh donc le l'agriculteur, le courtier,
le négociant, le port et puis
vous vous rendez compte ensuite et puis
vous suivez ensuite le bateau, le navire
de l'Égypte à l'Espagne qui traverse la
Méditerranée.
Et il faut comprendre comment ça
fonctionne.
Moi, moi je ne peux pas être sur un
cargo euh sur un cargo pétrolier et
piloter, mais j'ai mais j'ai voulu voir
ça pour avoir un une un sentiment
physique,
une expérience euh
de du phénomène. Pour revenir sur
l'exemple de votre réveil, le matin,
vous allumez la lumière. On pense que
c'est un acquis
mais il y a une chose qui pour moi a été
très intéressante avec le blackout en
Espagne. Vous savez la grande panne il y
a quelques mois,
les gens partaient du principe que que
l'électricité serait toujours là et on
en sait en fait rien sur la complexité
que ça implique, sur les sommes
d'argent, sur les efforts qui sont
requis pour que ces marchés fonctionnent
et pour que le système fonctionne.
Moi, mes amis ingénieurs, ils le savent
bien sûr, les ingénieurs savent ça, mais
en général les gens ne s'intéressent
pas, si vous voulez, à la plomberie dans
la société.
Donc savoir comment cette barre
chocolatée se retrouve dans le
supermarché, bon ça n'intéresse
personne. On ne s'intéresse pas aux
efforts qui sont derrière le transport
de ces
grains de de cacao euh jusqu'au
raffinage et jusqu'à l'industrie jusqu'à
l'industrie agroalimentaire. La seule
chose qui m'intéresse, c'est de dépioter
ma barre et de la manger.
On voit des incantation politicienne
concernant
l'énergie
nucléaire, l'uranium.
On voit le monde entier maintenant
basculer vers l'uranium, les centrales
nucléaires, la production énergétique.
Laissons de côté juste une seconde le
coût du cuivre qui est en train
d'exploser, ce qui va avoir un impact
sur les factures, y compris dans
l'acheminement de l'électricité.
Ce genre de petit détail, comme vous le
savez, passe bien au-dessus de la tête
de nos gouvernements et de leur
incapacité à anticiper le futur.
Rentrons plutôt dans le le dur, le
noyau, l'uranium. Est-ce que vous avez
travaillé sur ce minerai ? Est-ce que
vous vous êtes rendu compte que y
compris dans les stocks, les États
étaient un petit peu non chalant ?
Est-ce que vous pensez que toutes ces
incantations pour rassurer le public et
surtout les industries concernant la
production énergétique, est-ce que vous
pensez sincèrement
que ça va passer le stade d'autre chose
qu'une incantation, vu la disponibilité
des mines et des pays à fournir ?
Est-ce que vous pensez que nos
politiciens ne sont pas simplement
qu'une bande de mythomanes qui font de
la flû pour se maintenir au pouvoir ? Et
quand la réalité la réalité frappera
dans la facture que vous allez recevoir
ou que je vais recevoir ou l'incapacité
à pouvoir remplir des centrales
nucléaires de crayons de combustible,
est-ce que vous pensez que là les
responsables du manque d'anticipation
seront traduits à la fois au pénal ? Et
est-ce que les journalistes en charge
d'informer sur ce type de clé ? vont
passer aussi au pénal.
Sur le nucléaire, on a bien sûr l'enjeu
de l'expérience.
Bon, à part en Occident, à part la
France, on n' pas construit de centrales
nucléairirees depuis longtemps. On a
plus fermé que construit en particulier
en Allemagne, mais aussi dans mon pays
d'origine, l'Espagne. On ne construit
pas, on n'a pas cette expertise.
Est-ce que je suis inquiet pour
l'uranium ? Pas vraiment, car le prix de
l'uranium n'est qu'un n'est que
le prix suivra.
Je comprends, je comprends et je pense
qu'il va rester disponible même s'il va
augmenter, s'il va devenir plus cher.
Bien sûr, les prix vont augmenter mais
je pense qu'il y aura de l'uranium même
s'il sera plus cher.
La véritable raison pour laquelle
les factures vont augmenter, c'est la
construction des centrales nucléaires,
l'uranium misise à part. Ça coûte très
cher, beaucoup plus cher de construire
une centrale nucléaire que ce qu'on
pense. À chaque fois qu'on construit une
nouvelle centrale nucléaire, très
souvent, pas tout le temps, très souvent
les budgets sont dépassés et de manière
significative,
parfois deux fois plus cher que prévu.
Pourquoi ? Parce que ça fait longtemps
qu'on a pas construit des
infrastructures de cette nature et moi
ça m'inquiète quand on dit en Occident
qu'on va construire des des centrales
nucléaires. Donc c'est pas l'uranium qui
m'inquiète. Ce qui m'inquiète, c'est les
soudeurs. Comment est-ce qu'on va
ramener comment est-ce qu'on va trouver
les soudeurs qui ont le niveau pour
traiter les soudures des métaux des
centrales nucléaires ? Ça c'est une
profession critique, une profession dont
l'âge moyen est proche de celui de la
retraite.
On n pas de jeunes de 25 ans qui sont
apprentis et qui apprennent le métier.
Et on n pas non plus d'ingénieurs
nucléaes.
Les les jeunes qui font ingénieurs
n'apprennent ne vont plus dans cette
filière. Ils vont plutôt dans la tech.
Pour moi, c'est là qu'il y a une
pénurie.
Parallèlement à cela, je suis persuadé
que le nucléaire que le nucléaire jouera
un rôle important à l'avenir car il faut
une électricité de base.
Est-ce que ce sera la solution ? Non, ce
sera très cher.
Nous avons parlé de nouvelles choses
comme les petits réacteurs modulaires,
les SMR.
On pour revenir sur ce qu'on a dit tout
à l'heure,
euh ça fait des années qu'on parle de
l'effondrement de de l'économie russe.
Ça fait aussi des années qu'on parle de
la disponibilité dans quelques années
des des SMR et ça fait quelques années
que c'est disponible dans quelques
années. De même pour la fusion, ça fait
50 ans que la fusion sera prête dans 10
ou 15 ans.
fonction mes inquiétudes.
L'uranium bien sûr le prix va augmenter.
C'est ce qui va se passer comme avec
beaucoup d'autres matières premières en
particulier les matières que nous tirons
du sol, les métaux, les minéraux, mais
je ne crois pas que ce sera
véritablement l'élément critique dans le
renouveau du nucléaire. Il y a un manque
général de capacité à construire puisque
puisqu'on n pas construit, on est on a
plutôt fermé.
Revenons sur la responsabilité de
l'anticipation
et la responsabilité d'informer
quand il n'y a pas d'anticipation et que
les résultats sont flagrants concernant
l'industrie, la désindustrialisation
européenne, quand les résultats de
manque d'anticipation
sont flagrants,
est-ce que vous pensez en tant que
journaliste que il faut traduire les
incompétents au pénal ? Et est-ce que
vous pensez que les journalistes qui ne
font pas leur travail d'information
devraient être dans le même tribunal
pour le fait qu'il n'est pas informé
correctement ?
Je crois que les hommes politiques font
face à une sorte de justice qui
s'appelle les élections
et les journaliste et bien si vous
n'aimez pas, vous pouvez simplement
changer de source d'information.
Il y a de très nombreuses sources
d'information.
On a même pas besoin de de se limiter à
sa seule langue. Il y a des traductions
automatiques qui vous permettent
d'accéder à presque toutes les sources
d'information.
La quantité d'informations disponible au
au niveau mondial est juste énorme. Donc
je recommande à tout le monde de euh
choisir.
Donc si vous n'êtes pas satisfait de
votre personnel politique ou de vos
journalistes, et bien changez-en.
Donc dans le cas des journalistes,
prenez un autre journal, prenez une
autre publication.
Moi, j'encourage tout le monde.
J'encourage tout le monde à lire même
des journalistes avec lesquels on n'est
pas d'accord. Moi chaque matin,
je commence avec les journaux qui ne
correspondent pas à mes opinions
politiques. Alors peut-être que ça me
fait un peu augmenter ma pression
artérielle.
D'accord, c'est mieux. Alors, j'ai pas
envie de parler des noms de ces
journaux,
mais je peux vous dire que certains
journaux sont plus efficaces pour me
faire monter en pression que mon café du
matin. Mais je n'ai pas envie de lire
que des choses qui vont dans le sens de
ce que je pense déjà. J'ai envie d'être
confronté à une contradiction, même si
ça met parfois en colère. Il faut se
dire que vous pouvez également avoir
tort. Il faut s'informer et dans le cas
du monde politique, tous les 4 5 ans, on
a un bulletin et on peut on peut dégager
le gouvernement qui est en place.
Est-ce que c'est tout ? fondamentalement
oui.
On peut pas dire
au personnel politique
qu'il faut qu'il paye
pour pour leurs erreurs, on en aurait
plus.
Le prix
le prix qu'on leur impose, c'est de les
dégager puisque ces hommes, ces femmes
aiment être au pouvoir. Donc
perdre une élection, l'alternance, ça
c'est la vraie sanction.
votre livre, vous en avez vendu plus de
200000 exemplaires.
Combien vous gagnez quand vous
travaillez chez Bloomberg ? Et combien
vous avez gagné avec ces 200000
exemplaires ?
[rires]
Et bien, je ne parle pas de mon salaire.
Euh, on m'a toujours dit que voilà,
quand je parle à mon patron et que je
demande une augmentation, tout ça, c'est
compliqué. Donc tout ce que je peux dire
c'est que je j'ai la chance de
travailler où je travaille et j'espère
que mon patron n'écoute pas.
Je trouve ça génial qu'on me paye pour
faire un boulot que j'aime
de continuer à apprendre. C'est
absolument génial. Donc évidemment,
j'aime être payé, mais
je suis ceux qui aiment leur travail et
je me suis dit c'est normal ça mais en
fait je me suis rendu compte que c'était
rare et je me sens chanceux.
Euh alors je n'ai pas écrit le livre
pour gagner de l'argent.
Quand vous écrivez un livre,
les maisons d'édition vous dites vous
disent baissez vos attentes si vous
vendez un peu de livre, ce sera déjà
bien. Donc on peut jamais prévoir ce
qu'on va gagner et faut se contenter de
tout ce qui rentre. C'est très bien.
Mais Jack et moi-même avons continué à
échanger en se disant comment est-ce que
cette industrie le le trading des
matières premières n'a pas son livre qui
est accessible par tous. Et on s'est dit
mais quelqu'un a bien dû écrire un
livre. Il y a bien un livre là-dessus
non ? Et un jour, je ne me souviens plus
vraiment qui m'a dit Jack ou moi-même.
Bon, je ne sais plus. Bon, quelqu'un a
dit "Faudrait peut-être l'écrire ce
livre." Et voilà comment ça a commencé.
Et c'est pour ça que recevoir de
l'argent, c'est toujours bien.
On a eu la chance de pouvoir le lire en
partie
et on a vu quelques horreurs à
l'intérieur. On a vu l'horreur de la
réalité. on connaissait déjà parce que
on a aussi des informateurs dans les
salles de marché ou dans les mines ou
ailleurs. Le fait de le voir compiler et
historiquement prendre du recul
historique sur l'Afrique du Sud, l'Iran,
Israël et d'autres, quand vous vous êtes
plongé là-dessus dans l'écriture de ce
livre, le fait de pouvoir écrire
l'horreur
du marché des matières premières,
est-ce que vous pouvez donner un exemple
à ma communauté, à notre communauté
de du côté é horrif horrifiant
de ce marché.
Et bien
je ne sais pas si c'est l'horreur que
vous recherchez, mais
ce qui m'intéresse le plus sur le négoce
des matières premières et ce qu'on
raconte dans le livre, ce n'est pas
seulement l'impact des traders sur les
marchés planétaires, les activités
planétaires, important, mais l'impact
aussi sur la politique.
Ils peuvent façonner écrire l'histoire
et
nous avons commencé à vraiment réfléchir
au livre en partie parce que j'étais en
Libye pendant la guerre à Bazhazi.
Je suis allé plusieurs fois, je m'y
rends plusieurs fois. Je ne suis pas
correspondant de guerre, pas du tout,
mais voilà, je me suis trouvé dans des
zones de conflit en Libye, en Irak
aussi. Et j'ai vu un trader de faire un
euh un une transaction
pour fournir au gouvernement une ligne
de crédit afin qu'il puisse disposer de
de carburants.
Vous voyez, il y a
cela a un impact direct sur la la
poursuite de la guerre. Tout fonctionne
grâce au carburant et
il n'y avait pas de gouvernement en
place à l'époque, pas de centre banque
centrale, pas de ministère, mais un
trader de en pétrole est allé à à Bazi a
fait un accord avec le gouvernement pour
fournir ce gouvernement en pétrole pour
gagner la guerre et avec du crédit. Il a
été remboursé après la fin de la guerre.
En tout cas, la première phase de la
confrontation et bien sûr la guerre
civile
est a été active déjà bien avant. Mais
ça ça m'a choqué parce que moi j'étais
sur place et on m'a dit les militaires
m'ont dit que le carburant obtenu était
essentiel pour changer l'équilibre sur
le terrain. Et c'est là que j'ai compris
ces garsl ils ont un impact
sur le marché du pétrole mais pas
seulement. Il change l'histoire en Libye
et Jack et moi, on écrivait pour le
livre et on a trouvé tout un tas
d'exemples analogue
en Afrique du Sud, par exemple,
l'apartaille qui est a eu 10 ans de plus
parce que les traders leur fournissaient
en pétrole. Les fournissaient en
pétrole.
Castro
a pu résister à des crises parce que des
traders euh échangait le la canassu
contre le pétrole. Et vous avez tout un
tas d'exemples.
Et ainsi on comprend que les traders
jouent au magiciens, ils façonnent
l'histoire et peu importe si les
gouvernements sont de gauche ou de
droite conservateurs ou progressistes
les mêmes traders. Je leur ai demandé un
qui a travaillé avec Fidè Castro et
Pinochet au Chili, un un qui a travaillé
avec les deux,
le cuivre pour Pinochet et le pétrole
pour Fidè Castro. Je lui ai dit "C'était
plus facile de travailler avec les
gauchistes ou les droitsards." Et il m'a
dit "Moi, moi les couleurs, il n'y a
qu'une couleur qui m'intéresse, le vert,
le vert du dollar, tout le reste je m'en
fiche.
et ils sont apolitiques, amoraux, ils
sont portés par l'argent et c'est ainsi
qu'il façonnent l'histoire.
Et ce n'est pas un moment horrifiant. En
quelque sorte, j'ai compris qu'ils
avaient un impact politique, qu'ils
changeaient l'histoire et que personne
ne savait ça et qu'il fallait que chacun
le sache.
à notre époque
une guerre avec l'Ukraine une guerre
bientôt avec la Chine.
Il y a encore ce type de mécanisme ?
Bien sûr, bien sûr. À l'heure actuelle,
il y a des traders, des nouveaux au
Moyen-Orient,
en Asie
et il transportent le pétrole russe sur
la mer haute en Chine. Les
traders, si Poutine est encore au
pouvoir, c'est grâce à eux. Ils trouvent
les failles des sanctions. Ils ont créé
la flotte obscure avec des méthagniers
qui leur permettent d'échapper aux
sanctions euh sans battre drapeau,
battre pavillon. Les euh traders sont
encore très importants dans l'économie
planétaire et dans la politique
et je ne pense pas que l'on comprenne
vraiment leur importance. le rôle dans
l'histoire. Et je ne sais pas, j'ai
demandé à à beaucoup de traders, est-ce
que vous savez vous-même que vous
changez l'histoire ? Ils me disent "Non,
non, non, tu exagères. Moi, je je ne
fais que de l'argent."
Je ne sais pas s'ils savent à quel point
ils changent l'histoire. Peut-être
qu'ils sont obnubilés par l'argent, ils
s'en fichent du reste. Peut-être,
peut-être que certains le savent et ne
veulent pas le reconnaître.
Je voudrais qu'on parle du marché des
nourritures, de la nourriture, du grain
de
toutes toutes ces ces denrées
alimentaires qui peuvent être à la base
des meutes de la fin, des denrées
de
des stabilisations politiques. Je
voudrais savoir si vous avez vu
flagrante la manipulation des cours,
soit en créant des événements sur le
terrain, soit en influenc en influençant
les cours par une entente cordiale entre
les différents traders.
Et bien, j'ai vu parfois des traders
pousser des gouvernements à agir d'une
certaine façon pour leur profiter.
Glencor par exemple, le plus grand
négociant en matière première a fait
pression pour imposer une interdiction
d'exportation de certains certaines
céréales,
mais on ne peut pas arrêter
l'exportation de céréales, c'est très
difficile. Il faut toujours prévoir
assez de blé pour sa propre population.
On parle de la Russie mais évidemment
ils ils étaient longs sur le marché euh
de de Blé au cas où le prix augmentait
en cas d'interdiction. C'est ce que le
gouvernement russe a fait. Donc j'ai vu
des exemples qui montrent que les
traders poussaient les gouvernements
dans une direction qui leur profitait.
Il y a des exemples
où les traders falsifient ces
informations, certaines informations de
prix pour manipuler les marchés. En
général, je dirais que les traders en
matière première luttent contre d'autres
traders et il y a peu d'entente en fait
sur les prix. Certains mis à la hausse,
certains mises à la baisse, ils ne
peuvent pas faire bouger le marché par
leur seule volonté et sur le long terme
en tout cas. Mais ça est là. Ils peuvent
pousser le marché d'un côté ou de
l'autre.
Est-ce que vous avez vu des délits
d'initiés auprès des politiciens ? Vous
pouvez citer quelques pays. Et sur quel
type de position vous pensez que c'était
un pur hasard ou c'était un inside
trading ?
Et bien, je n'ai pas vu de responsable
politique faire du délit d'initié dans
ce domaine. Si je l'avais vu, je les
aurais signalé. J'aurais adoré le faire.
Euh est-ce que j'ai eu des suspicions,
des doutes ou qu'un pays en est-ce qu'un
pays entier peut miser euh sur la base
d'information d'initié ? Non, je ne l'ai
pas vu.
Je j'en aurais fait un beau reportage,
mais c'est important à savoir.
Il n'y a pas de délit d'initié dans les
matières premières.
Pas de la manière la même manière que
dans les actions. Par exemple, quelqu'un
dans les actions peut utiliser une
information pour prendre une position
dans le marché. Voilà, ça c'est légal.
Vous êtes une compagnie minière, vous
savez que votre mine va produire moins
moins de cuivre disons. Bon,
rien ne vous empêche de prendre une
position sur le marché et de négocier
sur la base de cette information dans
les matières premières.
Il n'y a pas le concept même de délit
d'initié comme pour le marché des
actions par exemple. C'est c'est
surprenant
à apprendre. D'ailleurs,
il y a d'autres faits surprenants dans
ce marché.
Le délit d'initié n'existe pas vraiment
comme il existe ailleurs. Ensuite,
la corruption
était acceptée et même légale dans
certains pays. On pouvait payer des pots
de vin. Les traders pouvaient le faire.
En Suisse, il y a un peu plus de 10 ans,
les la corruption était légale mais on
pouvait les déduire de l'impôt.
Jack et moi-même avons vérifié cin ou si
fois
en fait parce que on se disait non mais
ça peut pas être vrai, c'est pas
possible, ça peut pas être légal. Non
non pas déduisible en plus. Non pas
possible. Et on a demandé à des experts,
des fiscalistes en Suisse et ils ont
confirmé encore et encore que c'était un
fait
et et donc pas
horrible. Enfin bon quand même ça
compte.
Dans les années 2000, le gouvernement
suisse a permis de déduire des impôts,
des pots de vin.
Et c'est là qu'on a compris que certains
gouvernements vont aller très loin pour
maintenir le flux d'argent.
Je voudrais qu'on fasse une expérience
de pensée vous et vous concernant
l'Europe
et sa capacité
à survivre entre la Russie et la Chine,
entre la Russie, la Chine et les
États-Unis. Est-ce que vous pensez pas
que l'Europe est le dindon de la farce
de cette guerre commerciale ? Parce que
à force de jamais rien anticiper, elle
finit toujours par se faire surprendre.
Elle porte bien son nom, l'Europe.
Est-ce que vous pensez que cette guerre
commerciale qui est surtout basée sur de
l'énergie et des matières premières,
est-ce que l'Europe en fait n'est pas
déjà morte et que l'euro est déjà une
monnaie fantôme ?
Mort peut-être pas. Mort peut-être pas.
Nous avons encore des économies qui
prospèrent.
Moi, j'aime beaucoup être en France,
vous savez, à Paris en particulier.
Je crois que l'Europe fait face à deux
difficultés quant à cette guerre
commerciale. D'abord, c'est un acteur de
second.
C'est un il ne sait pas elle, cet acteur
ne sait pas ce que les Américains
veulent, ce que les Chinois veulent et
cet acteur est dans la réaction. La
deuxième difficulté, c'est que c'est
l'Europe. L'Europe en elle-même n'a pas
encore décidé ce qu'elle veut. L'Europe,
c'est un groupe de pays qui chacun a son
intérêt propre.
Dans le cadre de cette guerre
commerciale, l'Allemagne ne veut pas la
même chose que l'Espagne ou l'Italie ou
le Royaume-Uni
dans l'Europe. D'ailleurs, de quoi on
parle ? Est-ce qu'on inclut le
Royaume-Uni où je vis ou est-ce qu'on
les met de côté ? Je ne sais pas.
Donc on n pas d'approche harmonisée.
Chaque pays a ses propres priorité et on
voit parfois que ces priorités
s'opposent de fait les unes aux autres.
Elles sont contradictoires. L'Europe est
sur un strapontin.
Donc si vous dites que l'économie
mondiale est une voiture,
les Américains,
les Américains et les Chinois
se battent pour le volant qui est au
milieu. Le président Chie, le président
Trump se battent pour savoir qui va
piloter et l'Europe est gentiment à
derrière.
Ouais, c'est quelque part loin derrière
probablement.
avec les animaux, avec les animaux
domestiques, les chiens et les chats.
Bon, on est un passager
et on a pas grandchose à dire.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ce matin ?
On était scotché à nos écrans pour
savoir ce que le président Trump et le
président Chie allaient décider. On a
rien à dire dans ce débat.
Et les Américains n'ont pas consulté
les Européens sur ce que le président
Trump allait faire. Nous sommes vraiment
des des voilà des passagers clandestins
et c'est un gros problème.
Vous connaissez l'expression quand vous
n'êtes pas à table, c'est que vous êtes
au menu.
Et oui
et j'ai bien peur malheureusement que
nous soyons solidement au menu. J'ignore
par qui nous serons dévorés par le
président chou par le président Trump.
Mais de fait,
nous n'avons n'avons pas d'influence.
Il y a ces cette discorde interne en
Europe sur la façon de réagir et cela
bien sûr favorise
les Chinois et les Américains. Il voi
que nous ne sommes pas un et que nous ne
savons pas ce que nous voulons.
Combien de visites
combien de visites d'Européens y a-t-il
eu en Europe en Chine pardon ?
pas pour défendre l'intérêt européen,
mais pour défendre les intérêts de leurs
électorats nationaux. Combien de cette
visite y a-t-il ?
Idéalement, il faudrait que l'Europe
soit représentée de manière uniforme en
Chine et par une seule personne,
mais OK. Par un homme ou une femme, bien
sûr, et de manière uniforme par un homme
ou une femme aux États-Unis. C'est plus
facile bien sûr pour le Japon. C'est un
pays unique, une économie unique, une
grande économie qui sait ce qu'elle
veut, une économie qui est également à
l'arrière de la voiture mais qui est un
peu plus près du volant.
Et si on poursuit l'analogie de la
voiture avec le présidentiel le
président Trump euh qui se battent pour
le volant,
il y a à peu près 25 leaders européens
derrière qui tentent de s'approcher du
volant. Et lorsque l'un d'entre eux
s'approche du volant, un autre européen
retire la main. Les Japonais, quant à
eux, sont seuls et peuvent tenter de se
frayer un chemin au milieu de la mêlée.
Pour moi, c'est euh la plus grosse
source d'inquiétude pour l'Europe. Si
vous aviez un conseil à donner à au
gouvernement allemand et si vous aviez
un conseil à donner à l'industrie
automobile allemande, le premier serait
à l'industrie allemande en lui disant
"Il est temps de mettre votre
gouvernement à la porte parce que ce ne
sont que des annes en terme de
géopolitique et de guerre économique ou
est-ce que vous donneriez votre premier
conseil au gouvernement allemand pour
dire à l'industrie automobile la même
chose mais sans une capacité à faire.
Alors à l'industrie automobile
allemande, je dirais
je dirais la chose suivante.
Il faut que vous fassiez des voitures
que les gens veulent acheter. Un message
simple. Je pense que les voitures
allemandes sont très belles, elles sont
très confortables, mais elles sont aussi
très chères.
Et les jeunes, les acheteurs
d'aujourd'hui, les jeunes couples
qui ont qui sont dans qui ont la
vingtaine ne sont pas prêts à dépenser
autant d'argent pour une voiture que
leurs parents. Ça c'est le premier
message. Il en a un autre, un autre à
l'industrie et à l'État allemand. Il
faut que vous preniez une décision.
Si vous voulez avoir une économie basée
sur l'industrie, alors il faut une une
énergie pour marcher. Ça n'est pas le
cas. Cette énergie est certes verte mais
elle est chère et une énergie bon marché
est absolument cruciale pour l'industrie
manufacturière si ça n'est pas votre
objectif. Si vous voulez orienter accès
votre économie sur d'autres secteurs,
alors une économie à bas coup est moins
importante,
mais le prix de l'énergie a une
influence sur les coûts de production,
sur les salaires et
pour et quand on voit l'Allemagne, on
voit que et l'Allemagne est un pays
d'industrie depuis la fin de la guerre.
Mais ça n'est pas que la faute du
gouvernement. Bien sûr, c'est largement
la faute du gouvernement
car le modèle économique de l'Allemagne
est incompatible avec ce modèle
énergétique. Mais c'est aussi la faute
de l'industrie. L'industrie peut certes
se plaindre de l'État, mais l'industrie
doit se remettre en cause et se demander
pourquoi les consommateurs de beaucoup
de pays d'Europe n'ont plus envie
d'acheter des voitures allemandes.
Je vais vous lire une question que je
vais prendre au hasard de notre
communauté.
Bonsoir. Quel est son point de vue
concernant les négociants en matières
premières tels que Glencore
ou Transfigura sont-ils encore dominants
ou se sont-ils faits damer le pion par
les Chinois ?
Ils sont moins dominants qu'autrefois.
Autrefois euh ils étaient les seuls
jusqu'au début des années 2000. C'était
vraiment les seuls acteurs de premier
plan. Maintenant, ils sont en
compétition avec d'autres traders, pas
seulement les Chinois.
Les Chinois
sont un peu différents, sont des acteurs
un peu différents car le modèle
économique des traders chinois est
orienté vers la Chine, vers le service
de la Chine.
Men Glencore, vous achetez chez tout le
monde et vous vendez à tout le monde. Le
modèle économique des traders chinois
est d'acheter à tout le monde et de ne
vendre qu'à la Chine. C'est un modèle
économique très différent.
Si vous voulez, ce sont davantage, c'est
plus des acheteurs que des traders.
Ils ont une approche différente bien sûr
que les entreprises capitalistes comme
Glencore qui ont intérêt
ou les gens ont intérêt à faire des
affaires, à faire gagner de l'argent car
ils ont des objectifs.
Alors qu'en Chine
vous êtes responsable uniquement devant
le PCC, devant le parti communiste
chinois.
Et même si vous faites gagner beaucoup
d'argent à l'entreprise,
et bien euh si vous faites gagner
beaucoup d'argent à l'entreprise, vous
n'êtes pas particulièrement valorisé
pour ça parce que c'est votre mission.
Si vous en faites perdre, et bien euh ça
fait partie du métier, mais vous pouvez
être viré. Quoi qu'il en soit, les
Chinois sont de très sont des traders de
haut niveau. Il y a aussi d'autres
traders, des négociants indépendants au
Moyen-Orient et en Asie qui sont en
compétition.
Vous avez Glencore et Trafigura,
donc des anciens acteurs
qui sont
sous la lunette du ministère de la
justice américain,
qui sont sous la surveillance des
autorités financières
et ils ne peuvent plus être au niveau où
ils étaient auparavant
à cause des sanctions, de telle sorte
que le marché se déplace vers des zones
plus grises du marché. en particulier
vers l'est et ça ils n'en peuvent ils ne
peuvent plus en profiter à cause des
sanctions.
Alors ils ne sont plus les seuls
acteurs, ils sont toujours très
importants mais ils font face à une
concurrence qui est maintenant très
forte.
Quand vous avez discuté avec certains
traders concernant la déstabilisation de
gouvernement ou la modification, le
reshaping of state, du moins la la
terraformation de l'opinion
gouvernementale dans un sens ou dans un
autre. Est-ce que vous avez senti s'ils
avaient une âme ?
Onil une âme ? C'est une très bonne
question.
Moi je demande, j'ai demandé souvent
à des traders
qu'elles influencent leurs actions
d'échange
quelle conséquences ces actions avaient.
en particulier pour les zones de guerre
où lorsqu'on achète des convents dans
des pays très pauvres où le cours de
telle matière première peut faire
s'effondrer l'économie ou les finances
de l'État. La plupart du temps,
les gens sont complètement détachés.
Ce type de critère n'est jamais un
facteur de décision.
Donc soit ça me surprenait. Alors soit
il me mentent.
Peut-être qu'ils sont dans le déni,
c'est aussi possible. La meilleure
manière de travailler dans ces zones est
de porter des œillères, de mettre un
masque et de dire ça m'est complètement
égal. Je suis concentré sur mon
objectif. Je regarde pas ce qui à droite
et à gauche. Je regarde droit devant moi
et je fonce et devant moi, il y a de
l'argent. Alors, j'y vais en courant.
Mais il y a eu un moment où je parlais à
un trader trava pour Glencor et parlait
du marché de l'aluminium en Tikistan.
et il m'a dit la chose suivante,
c'était il faisait de très bonnes
affaires parce qu'il y avait une guerre
civile. Il achetait de l'aluminium
au gouvernement et c'était comme ça que
le gouvernement finançait sa guerre
et c'était
peut-être l'une des guerres civiles
liées à la désintégration de l'Union
soviétique les plus sanglantes dans les
années 90. Le fait que quelqu'un ait pu
dire "On fait des bonnes affaires grâce
à une guerre civile." Je crois que cette
phrase vous dit tout ce que vous devez
savoir.
Je crois que à un moment-là, ce type a
complètement laissé son masque de côté
et m'a dit la vérité et j'ai pas
vraiment eu ça avec d'autres personnes.
Et je crois que la plupart d'entre eux
en fait, ils vut surtout des
opportunités, c'est tout.
Il nous reste 15 minutes.
Est-ce que vous avez un sujet que vous
souhaiteriez aborder avec nous ?
Je suis très ouvert. Je crois que
nous avons échangé sur les enjeux
principaux. La réglementation bien sûr
est un sujet important.
Comment améliorer la transparence dans
le dans cette branche ?
Bien sûr, je pourrais défendre la
transparence, mais parfois les
législateurs me demandent qu'est-ce que
vous feriez et je n'ai pas vraiment de
bonne réponse à cette question. Comment
est-ce que vous améliorez la
transparence dans cette branche ?
Pour moi,
il y a une chose surprenante qui est
encore une fois que les gens au niveau
du gouvernement ne savent pas à quel
point c'est qu'on ces entreprises sont
rentables.
J'ai été invité,
je vous donne un exemple, j'ai été
invité à une conférence d'une banque
centrale. C'est un événement public euh
de on pouve trouver ça sur internet de
la Banque centrale européenne et j'ai
fourni un graphique sur la rentabilité
des quatre plus grosses entreprises de
trading de matière première sur 35 ans
et vous voyez ces courbes
qui explosent qui qui grimpent à fond au
début de la guerre d'Ukraine
et les gens qui étaient là les haut
fonctionnaires, les responsables étaient
complètement estomaqués parce que
c'était la première fois qu'il voyait
ces chiffres.
Donc informer mieux sur ça, ça serait
une bonne chose, je crois. Et ce serait
également bien si on avait de meilleure
réponse à la question de savoir comment
on améliore la transparence dans la
branche des matières premières.
Parfois quand je fais mon travail au
quotidien, je fais Bloomberg, je fais
face à une difficulté qui est d'accéder
à la donnée de bonne qualité.
Par exemple, quelle a été l'offre
d'aluminium l'an dernier ? La question
et la réponse c'est ça dépend des
sources. Il n'y a pas une source
officielle. Il y a différents chiffres.
Il n'y a pas un chiffre
fait par exemple donné par le FMI ou par
la Banque mondiale. Pour le pétrole,
vous avez l'agence internationale de
l'énergie qui donne des chiffres. Mais
pour d'autres types de marchandises,
d'autresutres types de matière première,
vous n'avez pas ces chiffres.
Moi, j'aimerais beaucoup
pouvoir vous en dire plus sur la
transparence dans le secteur,
mais je ne peux pas donner de bonnes
réponses. Je n'ai pas de proposition sur
comment améliorer cette transparence.
Si vous étiez le premier ministre
d'Espagne ou le président de la
République française ou le chancelier
allemand,
quelle serait votre première décision
?
les les matières premières ou en
général.
Ah
et bien je ne peux parler que de mon
domaine d'expertise.
Convaincre le gouvernement français et
allemand d'être d'accord sur moi que
l'huile d'olive est meilleure que le
beurre pour la cuisine.
Bon, il y a ça. Et puis pour ce qui est
de l'énergie, je leur demanderais
de regarder très sérieusement
nos actions
et d'analyser
gravement
la
l'intersection entre l'écologie et
l'accessibilité.
On on ne va nulle part avec des énergies
qui sont pas accessibles.
Et
si on doit choisir entre l'environnement
et les prix, les prix gagneront.
L'Europe a été dans le dénive
et reconnaisse la réalité.
Les électeurs ne n'accepteront jamais
des prix élevés
si vous demandez aux personnes de vous
aider pour arrêter le changement
climatique, pour répondre au sujet
climatique. La réponse universelle est
oui. Bien sûr, tout le monde veut une
planète moins polluée, plus verte, mais
la question essentielle à poser, c'est
combien êtes-vous prêt à payer pour ces
résultats ?
Et quand on pose la question, cette
question, c'est là que tout change. Et
je ne pense pas que l'Europe a vraiment
pensé les choses ainsi. Et
l'Europe pense en terme de perfection
éliminer le charbon à 100 %.
Alors que peut-être avec 5 %
les dégâts les
conséquences négative serait moindre
et éliminer à 100 % c'est trop cher et
peut-être qu'on peut éliminer 95 %.
Euh j'étais avec un grand dirigeant de
du pétrole récemment et
eux il parlaient de projets de
développement offshore
et ils sont beaucoup moins chers que par
le passé. Et je leur demandé pourquoi,
qu'est-ce qui a été le plus important
là-dedans ? Et il m'a dit
et bien on choisit les choses qui sont
bonnes à 95 % et pas 100 %. On fait
beaucoup pour la sécurité à 100 % bien
sûr, mais pour le reste on n pas besoin
d'aller à 100 %.
Oui, ce serait bien idéal que euh on
puisse produire 250000 barils par jour.
Mais si on arrive à à 235000,
et bien c'est bien moins cher parce que
ça implique toutes sortes de choses.
Faisons ça. Et puis on économise de
l'argent et la perfection coûte cher
parfois. l'ennemi, le mieux et l'ennemi
du bien. Donc, il faut viser euh la
l'accessibilité. C'est c'est là où je
suis assez un expert, on peut dire.
Est-ce que vous avez trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Et bien les livres, je peux vous parler
des livres que j'ai aimé
dans le secteur.
J'ai écrit un livre sur le trading de
matière commun matière première. Donc
bon, pour tous ceux qui s'intéressent à
l'énergie, lisez sur l'histoire de
l'industrie
The Price de Danerging
publié dans les années 90, toujours
actuel.
Dan
est un miroir dans lequel on se regarde
quand on écrit nos propres livres. Et
puis il y a un autre livre plus ancien
des années 70
que j'ai beaucoup apprécié, Merchant of
Grains
sur le négoce des matières des produits
agricoles. Et ça, ça vous présente très
très bien
euh
le monde de du négoce agricole et les
derniers jours de la guerre froide. Et
c'est tout à fait actuel parce que nous
avons la la guerre à l'époque entre les
États-Unis, la guerre froide entre les
États-Unis et et l'Urs. C'est c'est un
peu bis répétita aujourd'hui. Et un
autre livre que je vous recommande, la
biographie
de Daniel Alman, un journaliste suisse
qui a parlé de Nartwi.
On l'a utilisé pour écrire notre propre
notre livre.
Je je comprends ces actions aussi, mais
c'est là le profil d'un
d'un courtier, d'un trader qui a changé
le monde et et on voit là tous ces cette
manipulation, tout ce qu'il a fait pour
gagner de l'argent.
Est-ce
que vous avez un conseil pour les jeunes
générations ? une bouteille à la mer,
quelque chose qui va rester impérissable
sur les réseaux, sur l'internet.
Et bien lisez des opinions contraires au
vôtre,
des gens qui ne pensent pas comme le
reste du monde.
Je lis un journal
qui est opposé à mes convictions
politiques.
Trouvez un tel journal
et lisez-le tous les jours.
Oui, votre
pression artérielle va monter mais vous
verrez un monde différent, des opinions
différentes. Pas besoin d'être d'accord
avec tout
mais je dirais que c'est important de le
faire.
Euh moi, je donne l'occasion de parler à
des gens qui ne sont pas d'accord avec
moi dans mes propres chronique
parce que parfois avoir une vue
contraire est utile et ça me pousse moi.
Et c'est c'est important aussi hein
parce que quand vous lisez quelque
chose, ne plongez pas trop dans les
arguments. Comprenez les processus
pourquoi disent-ils ce qu'ils disent.
Commentil en sont-ils arrivés là ?
Pourquoi est-ce qu'ils misent à la
hausse ? Pourquoi il pense différemment
par rapport au marché ? Est-ce qu'ils
ont des données différentes de
meilleures données, leur interprétation
differtelle ? Pour en quoi est-ce que
leur analyse est différente ? Et
comprenez les mécanismes internes, les
rouages internes. Pourquoi ont-ils pris
les décisions qu'ils ont pris ? Parce
que s'il se trompe,
très bien, mais peut-être que ils ont si
vous vous êtes trompé et bien ils auront
vu certaines choses que vous n'avez pas
vu. Ils auront analysé les choses différ
différemment
contrairement
aux convictions reçues.
On parlait un peu plus tôt de la crise
financière.
Beaucoup
sonnaient tirent la sonnette d'alarme,
d'autres disaient tout va bien. Je pense
qu'il faut écouter ceux qui tirent la
sonnette d'alarme qui pensent
différemment. Pas parce qu'il se ne se
trompent jamais mais parce qu'il faut
comprendre leurs pensées. Et s'il se
trompent, c'est pas grave.
Et ce que je dirais tout
particulièrement, c'est que si vous
trouvez des gens plus expérimentés que
vous qui ont des résultats différents,
alors peut-être que vous vous trompez et
que ont raison.
C'est une bonne manière de penser et et
parfois voilà, on a raison alors que eux
ont tort.
Ça arrive aussi, mais je respecte les
gens plus expérimentés que moi.
Ne
lisez pas tout ce qui va dans votre
sens. Lisez tout ce qui vous dit que
vous vous trompez.
Ravier brass,
merci.
Merci beaucoup.
[musique]